et mon gars verre de mojito était moi je
donne tout à l'heure qui veut un mojito
ouais la beauté et la bonté mais c'est
quoi ce soleil
on n'est pas là pour rigoler on va
partir pour un cours de stretching mains
sur les hanches olive attention on va
commencer pape se dégourdir le fessier
attention c'est parti on y va musique et
2 et 3 on va chercher devant on va
chercher devant c'est bien
on y va maintenant chercher là
[Applaudissements]
gène couilles qui les battent
alerte couilles
[Musique]
je dois la vie maintenant
en position d'attenté et la vanille
chercher derrière
quoi
seul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
opel
et c'est bien
la scks en train de boire depuis le
début c'est une bande de taff tire au
flanc des as
alors maintenant ça va être bien ça
celui qui ne fait pas une extension jeu
le plc je vous fais c'est juste ok les
dom et noir ce qui en soi est un gâteau
gâteau ok d'accord y'a tu vas voir tu
vas d'être à des sommes beaucoup plus
vite
nathan et je veux rien entendre
d'accord je veux rien entendre la faute
aux faux
[Musique]
allez maintenant et pas ici et si une
fiche et si et si
attention attention c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
maintenant ce qu'on appelle du multi
gainage mokhtar tu vas venir te mettre
la tête plus grave est ok chez valeo
chien tu vas essayer de rester comme ça
avec doc gynéco qui va monter au dessus
de toi
attention c'est parti
on n'a pas le multi canal allez tu te
mets sur doc voile afin d'en mieux la
pâtisserie le millefeuille et dans les
milieux un petit peu olé olé le mille
club
khatami
on est tous les gros premier
[Musique]
doucement
non
voilà
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
j'étais pas bien grave si je voyais le
côté de la piscine oui bon j'allais vous
avez dix minutes pour y aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]